nice
sean mugum awesome
welcome
thank you
hey pleasure how are you doing
i'm great bro
i love what we were just talking about a
moment ago before we started
we were talking about how
we
have accrued a database a library of
content on our youtube channels and our
books
about what
enlightenment or awakening is
and
now that can act as a resource for all
of our other selves that are interested
in this topic
and
that's that's awesome and one of your
books um is titled the truth about
spiritual enlightenment
and i love that and i'd love to
um start things off by
asking you
what have you found
across your
different angles on this theme
to be
awakening
well um
the most important thing would be
the freedom from the conceptual reality
that people are stuck in because we
grow up learning the language learning
concepts about the world so we create a
representation of the world inside us
and we create beliefs about everything
including the person that you think you
are
and that is like a story you know a
story
in a bundle of thoughts emotions
memories
everything we get identified with it
and no matter what we read even when
when we read spiritual
things we always tend to
take everything conceptually another
concept to save in the memory identify
with but yeah the first thing was you
know in 2002
there was a realization
um
you know a realization of an
understanding of what spirituality is
really all about it is it has got
nothing to do with the books that i have
studied so far in my life i was
memorizing concepts you know
and uh maybe it sounded cool when i
mentioned those words like you know
moksha mukti
and samadhi things like that but i
didn't have anything in my experience
and
the the most
you know like shocking realization was
that it has got nothing to do with the
story that i am identified with the
story that i'm trying to improve you
know that story doesn't even exist it's
like just a story bundle of thoughts
so that was in 2002 i think it was like
a glimpse you know
uh realize realizing the possibility the
potential that relieved me a lot
even though i still suffer
much i think i feel that there's like an
insurance or something i don't lose
anything
and then it continued you know for 12
years and after that it was like
mind-blowing it was for me it was like
hitting a reset button it was like that
when somebody hits a reset button on
your brain you know you lose all the
conditioning suddenly you become like a
child everything is pure as if you're
just born
you know and uh
you don't think about tomorrow that's
how it was so it was it has got to do
with it it is very simple
no concepts to remember you know
no uh
it was not like you know it's it's it's
a it's a relief from a burden lifelong
burden and uh
it entirely changed everything
and uh i can say that it gave me a new
vision and new strength new strength to
sustain whatever that happens a new
vision
and
that also opened
me up to endless possibilities you know
mind-blowing and beyond words like you
know never
thought as possible
yeah
love that bro
so good
and it plays perfectly into
the
pali
the buddha teachings
where
nibbana
is unweaving
or unbinding or unfabricating
[Music]
very similar with nippapanka is the same
right so you're not mentally
proliferating
which is
self
others world
stories
all of that
and so then like the reeling back of the
mental proliferation so there's no
fabrication there's no weaving
there's no story
um
has been
recently so like beautiful
um revelatory
and huge shout out to rob berbea um and
actually frank yang who pointed me to
rob berbea um in his book um seeing that
freeze meditations on emptiness and
dependent arising
and
it's it's really when we
um
reel it back
reel it back
what is in innermost direct experience
and that's beautiful bro and um
and it's also really nice because now
we can
instead of getting stuck at one of the
conceptual layers like you said which i
think is so important also like
[Music]
mindfulness of breath
you know and just like you know just
like getting stuck
with the meditator is still behind the
eyes you know type thing um
[Music]
so there's all these layers that we can
still get
stuck in
and
i love that that's great so
now from the place of awakening or
realization where there's no
story that's operating the show let's
say it's more like the
it's like freedom spontaneity purity
child likeness yes yes yeah so talk
about that for a bit like um that
natural state
yeah
um
yeah it is like you can see things in a
in a very simple way you know um what
many people struggle with like for
example i'll tell you just one example
maybe the fear of failure you know
people do not try things just because
they
think that they will fail and a lot of
people don't do a lot of things you know
don't do efforts just because of this
and that is tied to the self concept or
the narrative when you don't have that
narrative you don't really have that
feeling of failure you can pretty much
do anything you want right so it is just
like that just like how a child you know
learns to walk
it falls down gets up walks again
and
it's it's fun for the child but we when
when human beings fall down it is like a
you know they have to recover they take
a long time you know and there is a lot
of rumination a lot of uh stories going
on in the head it always happens to me
you know and that reduces your
ability to try the next time but when
you don't have such a story when you are
not bound by it you can just do anything
you know
but initially there was an absence of
intention
like i didn't want to do anything at all
like there doesn't do nothing anymore
that's what that's how i initially
thought a lot of people actually have
this question like you know there isn't
a complete absence of any intention at
all how to get over it and it actually
happens by itself you know you finally
figure out because the the demands
whatever life you're living there are
always demands that you have to meet you
have to pay your bills you have to meet
somebody the next week you know so you
have to actually do something in order
to meet those demands and you train your
brain
again and it happens automatically
right like it is like you know training
your brain to
think about the future to plan things in
advance to try to change things even
though you still accept everything as it
is perfectly you still need to change
things in the world right so
these days you know i just like i have
very much adapted to that very much
adapted to planning you know doing some
action
because you know i have i've been doing
a lot of things which i never imagined
possible like going to gym you know
working out and things like that and
it's all fun i don't think about the
results and that's exactly how i get
results
no not getting fixated on where you need
to reach what we need to become
so yeah that's beautiful it's very
simple you know
so yeah and uh
the focus uh for my in my first book you
know i
i mainly focused on connecting science
and spirituality how we can approach the
whole subject in a scientific way
and it is possible many people think
that it is not possible because
spirituality
and science is separate but we already
have a field called psychology we study
mind the body
and there is transpersonal psychology
which studies
spiritual experiences and transformation
so i think you know that is like that
will be the next step in the spiritual
uh you know what is going on in the
world we will
make more scientific approach
you know scientific way of thinking
about this awakening
because when it's
thought about in religious way a lot
there's a lot of confusion a lot of
misunderstanding clashes you know
things like that so that's the barrier
for people who really want to
transform their lives
so cool because you and i both
are fascinated by the synthesis of
science and spirituality which
you could say is one of the core
interests of the one
because
of god
because
what is more interesting than
the
consciousness plus physicalism merging
together or science and spirituality
merging together or
um
the
psychology or the mind merging with the
matter or the external the internal plus
the external um the comprehender
of creation
right and there's nothing cooler than to
be able to synthesize those two uh and i
shinzen young called it
the century's trillion dollar idea
and i very much i very much agree with
that and as you were listing
transpersonal psychology that's also a
place where
um i got really excited uh around like
you know maybe like three
three or so years ago
and
[Music]
um
that's a key entry point on the
getting interested in consciousness from
a scientific way um for sure i love that
you brought that up and i could even go
and say that
um there will potentially be more
um
ways to add
to it by maybe calling it like
decentralized psychology or universal
psychology or something like that
um
and
there's that and then
i also in my first book high level
perception authored a good chunk of it
on the synthesis of science and
spirituality so again it's no
no uh
yeah it's a perfect alignment for you
and i to be in this
conversation together and also that
the
the way that we can basically measure in
a sense the
let's say
the biometrics of like enlightened or
awakened sages
um
we can see that the levels of rumination
or the levels of story the levels of
self
um are
not present
and then we can measure that via eegs
and fmris and whatnot
we can take that and then we can
leverage that as like a biometric
biomarker for awakening and then we can
yeah yeah that type of thing too so
there's a synthesis available there
which is really important as well
yeah yeah that's something that i have
in mind that that is the idea that i
have like you know it's uh in the future
maybe in the science will find a lot of
people record their brain state you know
like how their brain has changed
uh you know so that that way we will
narrow down the neutral correlates of
the awakening what exactly happens in
the brain and then we can actually have
that as a a way to find out if somebody
has reached the same
level of transformation or not you know
the the same awakening
there is already a good progress uh you
know in my book i have a chapter on
science and spirituality
and we
have some idea for example there is a
book that i have written about introduce
that book which is about the left brain
interpreter that is in our left brain
left brain is the seat of language and
there is a function in the left brain it
is called as left brain interpreter that
creates the story
it connects past and future and uh it
may tries to maintain a consistency
right and we need maybe you know we
evolved it for survival because we
needed that consistency because that
consistency put together all the
experiences this is me this is my past
and i shouldn't repeat these mistakes
in the future in order to survive but we
probably overdid it because in in our
times whatever that was scars you know
that is available a lot we have a lot of
food and we have obesity we have a lot
of
things in our story you know the story
is very very heavy we have added too
much to it and that is making us suffer
and this left brain interpreter is what
is responsible for the story and yeah we
you know that is a very interesting
topic actually so i wanted to mention
that something that has a good potential
for doing more research on
i like how it can be as simple as we
have added too much story and that makes
us suffer
and then the neural
neural correlates of the story making
which you feel is in the
um the left hemisphere
yeah yeah
left brain interpreter is the the word
the left brain is like there is a
interpreter yeah it is like you know it
seems for me you know as i understand it
seems like you know the left brain
interpreter and then the prefrontal
cortex and default mode network it is a
network in the brain they all work
together
uh the left brain interpreter creates
the story prefrontal cortex uses that
story to plan for the future
to make plans you know to delay
gratification and things like that and
default mode network is the network that
gets activated when we are idle so we
get reminded about things that we need
to do
and
that is good if it is very little like
you know adding some salt in the recipe
you know i use usually use an analogy
like the salt in the ocean water and the
salt
that is required in a very tasty
sandwich or whatever pizza whatever
snack that you like
so we have like you know just like
having too much salt we have too much of
that too much of planning too much of uh
agenda to-do list and that has become
very very heavy you know so
basically we are resetting the whole
thing the story is we are taking the
brain
away from all this identification and
then again we have to train our brain
consciously to do use the prefrontal
cortex default mode network everything
in a very productive way in a much more
you know creative way it is like
designing your own life
so it becomes an art rather than an
unconscious way of living and suffering
so that's very beautiful you know
like uh
yeah
it was like you become the artist of
your own life
create whatever you want
and uh one more thing is that you know
when you are after this
awakening the shift it is like
you don't you have already found what
you're looking for in life in general so
the ultimate question of life has been
answered what is that in this life you
know what is ultimately i want is has
been answered now you're free to take
your time and do things you know without
any fear
the existential fear or insecurity about
what the future is going to be is remote
and that actually makes you more free to
do things in a very efficient way
i can see it uh as a something which is
very true because i struggled a lot when
i was a child emotional problems you
know
like a lot of things rejection
sensitivity
and uh trying to be normal that is one
thing that i was struggling with i
should be like you know everybody else
and uh
now and that actually you know
created a lot of
problems in my performance i couldn't
perform i couldn't speak i couldn't
social anxiety and things like that but
i ended up writing a book starting a
channel that i never imagined all these
things is possible and it is this
awakening which gave me that strength
you know when you forget about the story
the person that you are identified with
everything happens there is a higher
power that takes over many things you
don't even have to worry about it you
know
so good bro
um
love that um
yeah we could say that
when
um
the
the stress
about self
um relaxes
that higher intelligence we could say
this infinite intelligence um more
effortlessly like lao tzu called it
this very effortless action this flow
it's so natural yeah um
and then also
um i love how
um one of the main reasons why that flow
can um really
just be effortless is because like you
said the ultimate question
of life is answered
and yes that was the fire
you know um
ramana and uh papaji uh talked about it
like a
um
a flame under the ass
that is fanned but you know it's kindle
right um and then that
i wanna know myself i to know myself i
want to know my true nature
like the moth dissolves into the flame
of the infinite singularity and then
um
yeah
so cool and then and then the
expression
of life
from that perspective
can then be
whole it can be pure it can be
um
in in service to life awakening to
itself and yeah that's the key thing and
then another key thing you brought up
which i feel is um really important is
um this
when we talk about the one infinite
creator
uh we talk about it like a stylist
it's like the painter
and so become the artist
of your life yes consciously instead of
the
unconscious programming
and so there's like a liberation from
the matrix conditioning basically
that is a human this awakening
and it um a lot of it has to do with
liberating ourselves of the patterns of
conditioning of the matrix that have
kept us asleep for so long and so the
classic thing is like 10 years ago
or 20 years ago for for for people is
you begin looking at well what is money
like what is that yeah like what the
hell is that thing um uh who owns
money um
and another one is um
like
what is time that's another big one um
yeah so anyway these fundamental
questions can create shifts like do i
really believe what the media
polarized propaganda um
why am i picking a side against another
side that's in my same country or
whatnot this type of thing um
so yeah these basic ones can help you
like liberate more into that like
effortless
free stylus of creation and then another
thing you mentioned i think so important
is
did you say let me see if i can get this
right so
the left brain interpreter
creates the story
then
the pfc the prefrontal cortex uses the
story
and then the
the default mode network ruminates on
the story
yeah yeah
it is like you know default mode network
is like we get reminders actually it is
that is how it is supposed to be
reminders about things that we need
to do
all these reminders are associated with
the feeling emotion okay and that's what
is bothering us like oh i didn't do it i
mean i'm not
for example i'm single i don't have uh
i have to find a girlfriend is
something that you have to do but it
comes with an emotion emotion of you
know not being good enough or you know
not being something like that you know
so everything has an emotional load so
uh
yeah it is like all these three things
work together but they are all
overloaded the story is so big so heavy
you know and the prefrontal cortex is
overloaded it can distract it can get
distracted very easily and default mode
network is also overloaded even when
you're idle you are you are under stress
when you're doing nothing you can't
really do nothing
you know
and people often find ways to escape
this
silence like they don't want to be left
with themselves they can't sit in a room
without doing anything
they need a phone they need somebody to
talk to movie or something like that so
because they can't face
the mind when it is not doing anything
it brings all the worries and anxiety
and everything
yeah go on actually you're saying
something i mean you're confirming i've
i was you got you understood it right i
mean
this is so good i i was also just um
feeling into like more um how you
have identified this scientifically i
love that like you identified
um more of the scientific let's say
regions of the brain and activities of
the brain
that are what we talked about
what buddha
shared as a papanka um this like mental
proliferation um
yeah yes yes and so
if um
if
if the left brain interpreter is this
like explanation generation let's say
engine of sorts um then that can be like
literally could be like papanka might be
like the left brain interpreter like
that explanation generation engine this
mental proliferation and
conceptualization
of self and others and world and stories
endlessly and then there's the
prefrontal cortex using all of that
explanation generation to usually to try
and get something from the world to feel
whole because it feels lack
it feels separation
location etc
and then
and then and then that rumination of the
default mode network um
uh you you also set a reminder like i
like that too the default mode network
is such a reminder like there's a moment
of like peace and not all of a sudden
you're being like getting reminded about
the past or getting reminded about the
future um and then there's an there's a
proliferation that happens into those
webs
and then the whole thing is to just like
boom
yeah
yeah
so cool
yeah because you know the the default
mode network there's actually a good
thing about it usually it is sort of
thought of as a bad thing in
spirituality because of this mind
wandering and things like that but mind
wandering has a purpose
if it is a like it brings
like you know i brings your attention to
many things that you have forgotten
about even for creativity mind wandering
is a very useful thing it is like you
know you
you're exploring everything that you
know and everything that you can expect
and uh with a little bit of what what it
is it is useful
and since it is overloaded you know get
all messed up
and there is another
paper uh written by
richard boyle you know i want to mention
this so that even people would be aware
it is called cracking the buddhist code
that is a very
uh i'm very impressed by his work
richard his name is richard b boyle
and the paper is called as cracking the
buddhist code
a contemporary theory of first stage
awakening this might be of your interest
and also you know people who are
watching might find this interesting
because he has a this paper has uh
everything like you know he has
identified
things
which mark this transformation
and he has given names to it like for
example you know this absence of
reification
you know and uh
the sense of separation
the ability to live in uncertainty
because that is one other thing that you
get after the freedom
we have a lot of uncertainty about life
why we are here that is
and said
itself but we are able to live in that
uncertainty as if it is a play after a
transformation but before this the
uncertainty looks very dangerous people
want answers to everything to
escape from this uncertainty but that is
not the case after awakening you can
live in a state of not knowing how the
future is going to be whatever happens
you can adapt to it no matter what
happens tomorrow i am ready to
you know flow along you know flow with
the wave like you're surfing in the
ocean
so
yeah
okay so a couple things here um sure one
of them is like you said that
once we sort of reel back on the
mental proliferation
and we have an absence of reification
like you said and like richard said then
from there we can use the left brain
interpreter
the pfc and the dmn
in their good ones we can use them in
the game yes exactly yes exactly i think
there is not enough awareness about this
spot especially how we have to
what needs to be done after awakening
like you know many people actually ask
about this one part which is also
mentioned by richard boyle you know
absence of intentionality that is a very
important thing the intentionality is
completely absent and this is
somehow you know it uh creates some kind
of uh
like you know uh other people are not
probably they are not happy about what
you're doing you know because everybody
else thinks in a different way and
you're not putting efforts to improve
certain things because everything is
fine for you you accept everything but
then what what it can do is like you
know this this
planning
thinking about future is actually like a
muzzle
if you don't use it
it becomes weak but you can train it
again but when you really train it and
use it when you harness the power it is
like you know you have swallowed the
limitless drug you can do anything
because all you need is time
no matter what you want to do you need
time like for example if you want to
write a book it takes time if you if
you're spending that time without facing
that
anxiety whether it will happen or not
what if it doesn't happen
what if it happens my life will be like
this
when this is absent you can do your task
take your time
and it happens
you know
without any
resistance or any kind of
suffering that people go through
recently that's what i am thinking about
like you know how to use it the best
uh all the resources that you have in
your body in your brain
everything you know
uh
a lot of people they they get trained to
use those things because the brain it
rewires itself according to what you
are giving the input
you know
and everything can be taken advantage of
including watching movies people will
watch movies for entertainment but
movies has a if you're awaken for
example movie has a different purpose
now when you when you watch the movie
the movie exposes you to the forgotten
world
what people
struggle with you know different aspects
of life different aspects of
the problems that people around you face
it actually somewhat you know it does
something to bridge the empathy gap
because empathy gap is a phenomenon
everybody has it
uh unless you and i have the same
problem i can't understand your problem
much that is called as empathy gap it is
a cognitive bias
and even though we
say that
awakening
improves empathy
and that's because you're able to see
things without the filter of your own
ego still there is an empathy gap you
don't really we don't really understand
how much other people suffer because it
is forgotten story for people who are
awakened so these are the things that
are not
written about talked about in our
spiritual traditions maybe they talked
about it but they didn't write it down
because it will confuse people i don't
know but uh you know there are a lot of
other possibilities for exploration in
this field you know many things can be
done
so yeah it looks the possibilities looks
amazing mind-blowing you know
and rather than trying to explain things
to people we have to show them what is
possible they will be amazed
love that
my gosh okay so many good threads here
um
so one of the ones that just came up a
moment ago
um
is to read um i'm gonna put the link to
uh richard
boyle's um
paper
in the
uh description of our video
and what i'm gonna do right now
is
and so people can read it because i i
found what you just said uh with sharing
this to be so important so let's go
ahead and read let's at least read the
abstract of the paper to
um the audience so
richard p boyle cracking the buddhist
code a contemporary theory of first
stage awakening
abstract
the theory proposes that what buddhists
call awakening is equivalent to pure
perceptual experience or the awareness
our perceptual systems would present to
us if they acted without interference
from our symbol processing systems
two forms of interference are
particularly apt to interfere
uncontrolled inner speech
and the distortion of perception to fit
reified conceptual structures
uncontrolled inner speech has been
linked with hyperactivity in the default
mode network dmn
which occurs when attentional demands
are low
reification occurs universally as
children construct their own social
reality from the culture into which they
are born
both the dmn and reification are
products of evolutionary processes
trapping us in social reality and
preventing us from entering perceptual
reality
research indicates that both sources of
interference can be overcome through
special practices and training however
and people who have experienced first
stage awakening report a pattern of
features that is consistent with this
theory
so you guys can find this link in the
bio below to read this um this is a
great recommendation sean moogan so good
um
cool so i'll stop thank you you sharing
yeah such a good one and it's great to
just even take a bit to to read that
together so
um
so that and then
another powerful thing that came up was
when
um
when we talk about the absence of
reification of the abscess of
intentionality what comes up for me
immediately is shunyata emptiness
and
it's almost like
we
we reel
the
the expression of life back
word
into its source you could say into this
black hole this void
and then
because we've now tasted that we now
know ourselves as that we've maybe even
bathed in it
but we're not stuck there
because emptiness is empty
itself
so we're not stuck there we haven't
reified again the crown of emptiness to
then be something
but instead from from there
we from there
so we would say that there's
no intentionality
and
intentionality of the stylus of the
creator at the same time so it's like
the avoiding it's the avoiding of the
void but you but you've experienced both
now you taste both now you are both
simultaneously
non-existent existence non-being being
etc
so it's
you you you are the entanglement of that
simultaneity the superposition
yeah
yeah yeah it's excellent
yeah it to be it was most important like
you shared a bit of go-to
it's about being like you want the
beingness of that entanglement or that
superposition you want the frequency or
the vibration of it
and so to teach that um
is core is key
richard boyle has also written a book by
the way it has uh
the book has a
list of interviews with people including
shinsen young the one he one you
mentioned
shinsen and a few other teachers he had
interviewed a lot of people asking about
what happened in their lives you know
how
they view reality after transformation
and that is also a good source
i don't i think it's
let me see if i can find that book maybe
i can let you know
the name of the book
yeah it's called realizing awakened
consciousness
interviews with
this
teachers and a new respect the mind and
that's uh like you know he's done it in
a very scientific way
and uh it is also something that can be
it is like a database similar to your
youtube channel you know
teachers
of awakening explaining about what they
went through
and then there is a
textbook of transpersonal psychiatry
that will be a good book if somebody is
actually studying transpersonal
psychology you know
and uh that is actually a very good
field maybe you know it is very
promising it's going to be a promising
field in the future in the next 10
years you know a lot of people we might
have vacancies job vacancies and things
like that that because
it is a very promising field of study
and this is i think this is the the only
textbook available for that field it has
everything
document you know articles from many
people including ken wilbur
and uh many people have
done research on this
awesome recommendations those two
textbooks personal psychiatry and
psychology and realizing awakened
consciousness interviews of buddhist
teachers and a new perspective on the
mind
um awesome awesome book recommendations
also
um i can put those in the bio also to
the video i think that's great to have
these um all in the bio
nice bro so good
um and i love another thing that you
mentioned i think super important is um
the empathy gap
um
that's why the bodhisattva vow is
so prominent also
because
um
the
in a sense the bodhisattva vow is the
um
like your heart it's like the meta
component is still so prominent and it
um
and it is um where you where you feel
yourself as the totality
and
you are um
with your paintbrush your stylus
that you're drawn
to
express
in a way that shepherds the rest of life
awakening
um
and that way there's no empathy gap
because otherwise
um
the empathy gap can grow too big with no
intentionality
um yes yeah and yeah and then we're um
and then we're in a sense we're watching
another self
that is trapped in story
and
then the pointing is too absolute you
could say um
and
yeah because it wouldn't have worked
like for me 10 years ago no way like an
absolute pointing wouldn't have worked
to snap me out of story um so there was
just yes yeah there was the incremental
dissolving of the story yeah
yeah
yeah
and uh the one thing is you know a lot
of these traditions
they isolated
from the social life like for example in
buddhism uh people who
were seeking enlightenment they
renounced everything they lived in
monasteries and
in one way it is like you know you're
experimenting things in a in a
professional settings like for example
using a drug uh in a doctor's office
under the supervision you know a lot of
experienced people who have already been
through awakening you're separating
yourself from the social life under
their supervision you're trying out all
the medication and things like that it
was a convenient way but the thing is it
compromises on the
the social the growth of you know how an
individual can perform your performance
and skills that is compromised
like when you face the society when you
pay bills when you go to work or when
you are living in the society just like
everyone else it is very different you
are training your brain to think like
everybody else at least to some extent
you are witnessing their problems
and yeah in modern times it is very very
necessary because
these days people don't want to go to
monastery that's not a good idea either
you know it is the best thing to do is
just live your life and then
bring these spiritual practices as a
part of your life without
compromising on anything you know your
relationship your work everything should
go smoothly and that is a bit tricky
because a lot of people complain you
know about their spouses getting too
spiritual too meditative and that
creates cl
matches you know
so uh you know maybe in the future uh
you know with the work of a lot of
people you might have a very efficient
way of doing all these things you know
monitoring exactly when science grows uh
enough to study this more efficiently we
can document everything that happens
you know how their marital life is
affected how their uh performance and
job changes because it is like a
double-edged sword on one side you are
able to be in the present moment focus
and do your job well but the other side
the
when you when you progress spiritually
you are
giving less importance to all the
materialistic things pushing for
promotion competing you know with other
people and things like that and that was
a challenge for me too like you know
after 2014 for six months i even forgot
why i was going to office i was working
in a call center
and
it was like for six months it i went
very deep in meditation it was every
after every finishing every call the
wait time i was just focusing on what is
going on inside me how my body was
moving each and every impulse
and i was listening i was
performing amazingly in fact there was a
quality department which gave me a very
good
mark for addressing everything on the
call a complete call but my sales
performance was declining because i was
not pushing
customers to buy the product it is like
that you know in inbound call center and
i have to
push
and
usually people i mean
the temptation is incentives but i
didn't care about incentives much or
promotion or anything like that i forgot
it completely and that is
what will become a challenge for
spiritual seekers these days
how
they meet the expectations of other
people around you you know like
everybody else has a pride about you too
you your spouse your girlfriend or
boyfriend your son they are proud of you
even though you're not proud of yourself
i mean that pride is
doesn't it doesn't have the same meaning
anymore for you but it does for other
people who
you know who
yeah so in some way there has to be some
kind of empathy we can't simply dismiss
that as an unconscious behavior it is
just an expected behavior of everybody
you know depending on
the level that they are at you know the
identification that they are going
through
so
i think that will be the you know the
next thing that can happen which might
benefit people
yeah this is cool so
a
analysis of
this first stage awakening and the way
that it
both let's say plays into the
uh empowerment let's call it empowerment
and enlightenment so enlightenment is
the turn inward all the way
and empowerment is the exciting
expression of life outward creatively
and so yeah
so then
so we could have an analysis of first
stage awakening enlightenment to turn
inward and the way that it affects the
turn outward in terms of potentially
let's say some in sometimes this
decrease
in like intentionality or like drive for
empowered success must
earn money and prove worthiness and
increase self-image for sure those
things like tend to decrease
but
what's interesting is with that analysis
we can also see that the purity of the
expression when it does express in its
empowered creative state
is much less about wanting to get
self-image or wanting to get worthiness
or validation
because it comes from a whole place that
has no lack and it comes from a place of
wanting to shepherd the rest of life
awakening from that bodhisattva vow so
i think that that's a powerful way of
viewing it what we just got to this like
analysis of the effect that
enlightenment has on empowerment that's
cool yes yes yes yeah
yeah while we're talking
i'm taking
notes
and i feel like
there might be
a
deeper collaboration or creation between
us
where we
hone in on this exact
theme
and i'm seeing it come up more and more
between
the other selves that i'm getting
tighter and tighter with
is that
we're honed in on basically like
different angles on this exact theme
like the synthesis of science and
spirituality and whatnot
and and it's exciting feeling about
creating with you for sure
yeah
nice me too
yeah it's uh amazing amazing to
talk about it and
you know
move things forward
in that direction
and it also feels like
when
these let's say two points in the
tablecloth
come together
from very awakened places
that
their dance
is quite
empowered and accelerative
the
like exchange of symbols from an empty
place is like really powerful
yeah yeah
certainly
yeah and with the interaction you know
as you mentioned you know uh there is an
uniqueness
to everyone's
viewpoints they have it's all
complementary and uh
you know
so it helps to get more clarity on this
i mean how
things are things are affected
everybody has their own story to tell
about
um
you know what happened after awakening
and
you know
things that changed
their perspectives
and things like that
and also one more thing that i want to
bring up is uh
the uh
neurodiversity the concept of
neurodiversity it is a very interesting
concept because a lot of people that i
have
spoken with
they have
problems like adhd
autism bipolar disorder
and uh
a lot of people
even shinsen he had adhd he suffered
from adhd and
uh it looks like uh you know
these things are not really disorders it
is just that they have some uniqueness
they are different and
um i think
adhd might be very common among
spiritual seekers so we might even get
clarity on these things what exactly is
adhd
and how we can
you know
help people who have these symptoms
because it is certainly not a disorder
it is just that they are motivated
because of things like novelty
if something is novel
something is challenging you're going
for it and these kind of people are
needed for society they don't have a
disorder they just can't live like
everybody else they always are in
pursuit of new creative things they take
risks they get distracted very easily
because a lot of things are interesting
in the world so it is not that they
don't have a prop they have a problem in
paying attention it is just that
regulating their attention is difficult
because a lot of things catch their eyes
and uh
um so it is like you know they have more
uh like you know
they indeed have more potential but when
the life is like you know you're
repeating the same thing every day
it is not challenging for them and they
can't
do that job well
you know
i had adhd myself i just didn't know
that it had a name for it
uh only recently i realized uh that it
is adhd that i was suffering from
and it was misunderstood a lot um people
it is it is thought as a lack of
attention but it is more like you know
you either don't focus at all or your
hyper focus when you find something that
uh that you like you just
do it i mean
uh without even you get into a state of
flow so that is what happens with adhd
people
and uh
yeah that is uh like you know
there is an overlap between these uh
um the the disorders in these spectrum
and the spiritual seeking
they always even love to ask questions
you know to people if they were
you know they have adhd or things like
that sometimes you know if it is
relevant
because
yeah i'm i'm speaking to a people a lot
who have these problems they have
bipolar disorder uh you know or autism
things like that
do you have any experience of i mean
getting these uh like you know
talking to people who bring up this
topic the same thing
yeah this is great i love this topic as
well um one that came up not only adhd
and bipolar but also autism
is another one
so
it's this
like you described already so well
um
there's a
like there's a hyper
activity
around novelty and around
um becoming like masterful
and
um and not fitting into the matrix
um at all
and
there's the spectrum i think like we
said is really important where
there's um very like you could say um
it can be really tough to be um
plagued by let's say adhd or bipolar
autism in ways that are
non um don't serve enlightenment and
empowerment let's say
but when it does serve it which as on
let's say the good side of the spectrum
i mean
the amount of times that i've been
called uh
autistic or adhd or bipolar i can
already say for the last like 15 years
i've been
called or like
diagnosed and
that
every time there was every time there
was something inside that was no
no like i don't need your
pharmaceuticals like i i don't i
actually don't want to calm that down
there's something about it that is so
true
about um
what's being activated here and i just i
also yeah and i also feel the importance
of how
um
we could say like the negative polarity
of the one or of creation can come
through the matrix agenda can come
through the big pharma companies and can
come through
the
um the the quenching
of the of the drive of the awakening
out of the matrix
by plaguing with these um pharmaceutical
recipes
for the quelling of said accelerative
potential states um of exploration
so i that's another interesting
component because i've had several
friends
that were oh my gosh lit up in their
journey of awakening and then bang
um got prescribed pharmaceuticals
because family uh pressured them and
whatnot and then boom um all of a sudden
it's like back to
zombie
what the [ __ ] back to unconscious yeah
yeah
yeah it needs more uh like you know i
think uh this field needs to grow a lot
when it comes to the mental disorders
there is something
you know that we don't know yet about
these disorders very clearly
so
you know so i think that it is not
really a disorder like for example
bipolar it's uh probably you know it has
a
you know we don't have a complete
picture yet
and there's a lot of misdiagnosis too a
lot of in this area people can be
misdiagnosed very easily a lot of
confusion even doctors do not know much
about for example one doctor i talked to
he didn't know that adults can have adhd
like it is not something that
only affects children it is just a
lifelong it is like a trait actually
and there is a there is actually i i
don't remember the name of the person
who said it but it is a doctor and he
gave a different name
it is called
vast vasd variable
attention stimulus trait uh people who
are labeled as adhd people are actually
they have their nervous system works in
a different way they have
interest based nervous system not
importance-based nervous system which
means that
they don't
do things based on what is important
they're always
you know they are motivated their
attention is directed based on interests
passion
and novelty is another important factor
too you know if something is novel they
are bound to do it
and yeah there is also emotional hyper
you know reaction sensitivity and also
emotion emotional sensitivity too like
they have intense emotions
and
and
looks like you know he has a more clear
way of uh putting it well
telling exactly what it is you know
and
personally i suffered from a lot of
issues and i didn't even know what was
wrong it was like you know for me it was
uh
everyone usually says that my childhood
was wonderful and then
after that it became you know hectic and
then i lost mother fun that i had in
childhood for me it was totally the
opposite
childhood was less fun it was miserable
and then you know it improved and now it
is like i am the happiest like you know
it is
sometimes feel like i'm the happiest
person around i couldn't you know i
can't really find anybody else who is
this happy you know and uh but my
childhood was entirely the opposite it
was like you know i something is wrong
with me and uh i didn't know how to
explain the problem
and
a lot of things happened and you know i
wish i mean some i mean i i really think
that it should improve so that we don't
have i mean
other people do not face the same
problem or go through the same
situation
the struggles and everything that i went
through
yeah which is ultimately what we're
passionate about is
um
yeah the generation of content that
shepherds life awakening
without falling into the same pitfalls
and struggles that we went through
and yes yes that's huge and then
um
another thing that
that came up while
while you were sharing was of course to
not forget uh the infamous
schizophrenia
that's another one yeah um
so to add that to our list
because
um
there's a clear spectrum there as well
where it can be totally disastrous but
where it's also like
it is awakening like your your sense of
quote reality
is no longer
the
world and the stories um and so of
course yeah yeah so of course it can be
that's another one that came up for
friends as well is
that
it was a diagnosis as they were
awakening of schizophrenia
by their like family and the friends and
then um
and then just getting pumped with
pharmaceuticals
it happens a lot yeah you know
yeah
um basically
this new analysis of um awakening from a
psychiatric angle is gonna be crucial as
well
yeah that's yes the sum of it
to
yeah
yes because uh since he mentioned
schizophrenia i think uh you know i can
say something about it too
um schizophrenia one of the symptoms is
when a person is not taking care of
himself like grooming for example not
dressing properly not wearing good
clothes that is a symptom of
schizophrenia and as a person who is
spiritually inclined
is more likely to i mean less likely to
take care of these things like you know
grooming and things like that wearing
impressive clothes he's more interested
in meditating and things like that and
you know that yeah a lot of other things
too uh
like for example even talking about
things like aham brahmasmi it can be
misunderstood very easily like a
delusion
another symptom of schizophrenia he
thinks he's god
so
that is like a case of schizophrenia
right but uh it is not really the case a
lot of people don't understand these
words like alhamdulillah mostly
and
you know
things like that
so yeah there are a lot of misdiagnosis
that can happen and transpersonal
psychology in fact in the textbook of
trans personal psychiatry and psychology
you can see this mentioned
the main reason why this field evolved
as a separate science is because of this
misdiagnosis happening to people who go
through spiritual awakening they are
diagnosed as
somebody
who is having a mental disorder or
schizophrenia things like that even
about ramakrishna paramahamsa i think
that is the book i have not read it but
the book is about he had some kind of
temporal lobe epilepsy or something and
uh yeah it happens a lot it's very
common
that i think this field itself needs a
lot of introduction trans personal
psychology is only if we if people know
about it a lot of people will actually
study the material or you know they will
show interest and uh
just uh
just
experiencing meditation for like you
know 15 days retreat they it can
actually help them to
get a glimpse or really understand what
it is about you know all they have to do
is just one meditation retreat or
something but the people are really
scared about meditation in general
because
of you know getting into cults or you
know because of promises false promises
that are made in the name of
spirituality things like that
so if if it's made scientific
then
you know uh
that is the only thing that they need
like you know an experience of
meditation or even
using psychedelics in therapeutic you
know
medically supervised conditions that is
discussed a lot in this book trans
personal psychiatry a lot of research
has been done
on various psychedelics
they have the power to
give a glimpse you know
show what is possible but again yeah it
has a downside to you can be on
psychedelics all the time and that would
be
you know that wouldn't be good for your
brain you're training your brain
giving a different perception of reality
to your brain your brain is not getting
trained to face the actual challenging
situation you know that is in front of
you
yeah because managing something when you
have a drug in your
uh brain is might be easy
and you're not seeing the actual picture
you're not really seeing it is like
doing a bench press with uh supported
bench press or you know working out in a
gym but you're not using free weights
you're using some machines
it makes things easy but it is not
really an effective way right all the
time
you have to face the actual stress
but yeah chemicals do help in
opening up people
making them open-minded making them
realize what is possible
i think in the future we may we might
have non-duality pills or something like
that
some kind of you know
swallow a pill you have a glimpse of
non-duality which is what
it's what anthogens are
your magic mushrooms
dmt etc are all
um
usually
um glimpse generators
and
yeah
and another analogy to this is taking a
gondola up the mountain with the
entheogen which again just means
unleashing god or the divine from within
and then the gondola comes right back
down after getting to the peak
and so
very similar to your analogy of using
the assisted
weight
machines
so
the
antiogen
is a glimpse generator and then it's up
to the individuation to
further generate more of the natural
state that the entheogen glimpsed for
them
in essence
and that's not an easy process because
it's totally deconstructive
it's destructive
because um
there are so many
uh i've also called them neuro knots so
they're like neural knots tangles
right
and that to untangle them
um
to not have these trigger cascades
happen in the
proliferation conceptual mental
it requires
concentration it requires meditation it
requires
this
like this depth of self-inquiry
that
is not for
um we the weak
it's it's really only there for those
that want it so bad and so it's just
like it's just like picking up a musical
instrument or picking up a sport
um or picking up entrepreneurship you
know
the statistics keep changing but it's
somewhere around like
95 or 98
of entrepreneurs fail uh their
businesses that they started in uh
within 10 years
and that's the thing that you're that
we're sort of
um it's the same drive that when you
wake up every morning for your
entrepreneurial success
um
or for your sport or your musical
instrument success is the same thing for
self-inquiry
and focus
and meditation success
so
that it's that level that um dissolves
the neural nots
that are
um constricting
our
expression
and
i found that the neural not is um in
many ways like
um another good way of
of uh
of tying in
neuroscience
of neurology with
um awakening
because it is like uh it's basically
ossified pathways
that are
that the individual can't easily
liberate themselves from
so they become so
so associated with their name
ah i am atlas
i have these five symbols that are
strung together that define me and who i
am and so you know one of the greatest
ones is to dislodge in self-inquiry
those little string of symbols that
we've attached to this piece of life
things like that
yes yes
actually the word not is a i think is
the really good word word choice because
even in
sanskrit we have a word called granti
you might have heard about it kranti and
uh it literally means not and we have
nots that we need to
you know untie like so that is a perfect
analogy not because that is exactly what
it is like you know once it is free once
the knot is untied there are a lot of
such knots actually
uh you know there might be in in yoga
they talk about three knots
one knot is called as brahmagan brahma
granthi brahma gana granthi is about
your uh the knot that this that is that
is uh you know everybody is entangled
that not it is about survival you need
to earn money you need to follow what
everybody else is following you need to
have a big house so it is all about
survival and security the next not
vishnu grantee is conceptual the
conception or not it is about me the ego
i have to do this i have to accomplish
this it is all about conceptual you know
the personal growth i have to improve
this and that i have to so that is about
me and then the
one is about the ultimate like you know
uh the the identification
the second one is conceptual about all
the not it's not just self it is about
my country it is about my group it is
about all concepts that we carry
including the religious concepts
so conceptual not and the third knot is
actually the not of
the actual duality
i am different and the existence is
different that is the final knot
once the other two knots are untied
the last knot which is about the
separation the knot of separation can be
also
removed and then there was no separation
at all
so yeah that's a really good word
actually
so let's play with that a little bit
more
um
i love that so granty uh not in sanskrit
so cool so
i love also how the knot can be applied
to the blockages in the chakras of the
energy flow is another one and then the
freedom from those unblockages so that's
another great way to visualize the knots
and then so let's see if i got this
right so
brahma vishnu and rudra
and yeah so
so brahma is sort of like the
identification with others and world
uh the drama is like the basic like you
know uh following the routine uh to have
a secure life
what everybody is trying to do in
general you know i have to study i have
to earn money i have to settle so it is
more about the instinct of survival and
security cool and the next is conceptual
more about the concepts that we are
dealing with
and the third is the uh you know the
separation
okay cool so
so the first one can be kind of like the
matrix or like following the joneses or
following the protocols of the
collective and then then we have like an
um
we could say like a
more of the that's more instinctual
survival vishnu being more about um
conceptual specifically you said like
identity like me
and identity right
um cool yeah all kinds of concepts that
we that bind us you know the binding
concepts it can be anything like
religion or ambition okay
cool so binding concepts
and then the last one being about
duality rudra is the nod of duality
which then liberates into from
separation
yes yes
okay
nice
nice i love those i'm also gonna
dive deeper into into that because i
love that that's not such a good way
yeah to put it
yeah
the explanation that i gave it is like
my interpretation because uh you know it
is like a lot of different ways i mean
that that these knots are explained but
when i looked at all these definitions i
this is what i came up with like a
bottom line you know what i understood
you know as
meant by these not from my perspective
you know that's what uh
yeah
but yeah it's uh
i think it explains a lot not as
it is even after you untie it is the
same but it becomes so simple
right it doesn't have those
complications
wow i'm feeling so good about this first
conversation together
awesome yeah yeah me too it's been i
think it's been talking for like
more than an hour probably yeah
on my end too
a little more than an hour
um
yeah
yeah i'm feeling great like i'm feeling
complete i feel like there could be
another potential to explore on this
first
um well yeah sure we can do that it's uh
yeah it's it's an awesome discussion i i
love that i mean whatever we are
discussing so far it's a
wonderful opportunity for me to
you know connect with you
youtube
me too
especially the depth of of understanding
yeah the way that it
springs up with with you
um i feel a great amount of uh
resonance magnetism
um alignment
synchronicity the puzzle pieces can fit
well
good
yeah i think in the future we can talk a
lot about the uh
the the
concepts discussed in transpersonal
psychiatry textbook you know because
that is something i feel like it needs
to be known you know
this textbook is it's very hard to read
for people i gave it to a few people and
they said you know it's very complicated
it's very academic but we can break it
down in our discussions so that people
find it easy to absorb like you know
people get introduced about all these
work that has been done
uh it is there for since 1968 so
it's been
yeah
50 years now
but
this field is still not very well known
and the hard work that has been done in
this field is not really
uh very well known either
and we still find people who you know
think meditation is somewhat religious
practice doesn't have any value you know
so
this certainly needs a lot of uh
introduction to people it can change
lives
when people are aware of all these
possibilities
yeah
yeah i love that um
i love
how um we can
like further
um together
especially um the science spirituality
synthesis take it from that approach
and then that will automatically make it
more familiar and friendly to mainstream
audiences
um yes great
i love that
and that resonates so we can
we can explore that on our on our next
chats
um
i just have some silly questions what is
your favorite yeah what's your favorite
food
favorite food oh it's uh
it keeps changing actually uh
i love
non-vegetarian food actually fish
i love fish very much it might sound
very shocking for many people who are in
non-duality people always ask me oh do
you eat non-vegetarian
yeah i do because i grew up differently
for me non-vegetarian food was like a
dream because i was in vegetarian family
so everybody is different
but yeah i
love
baked fish i bake myself i have an oven
and that
that is very tasty and
yeah all kinds of uh food and these days
i'm finding fruits and nuts also because
i am moving to more healthier choices
i'm passionate about health finding out
about how this body works
you know because uh
human physiology is not like a subject
anymore it is about what this instrument
that is how i see it now we can
we can see things as it is it is like
you have the user manual in your hand
when you have a book about physiology
we learn about the cell you know we
learn about dna so i started exploring
health and
i eat dry fruits berries you know
cranberries and
nuts
so all of them i like very much
yeah go ahead
without your other questions
cool
what do you like for
um hobby
do you like a specific like hobby
um
i i have a lot of hobbies actually i try
out everything singing i i'm learning
music these days just uh you know when i
when i take a walk in the morning i
learn classical music that is a hobby i
work out and that is a hobby for me i
mean everything that i do is a hobby
actually
reading you know and then
been improving working on all kinds of
skills that i
you know i i
felt some kind of fear in even trying
them out because of failure but now it
is no longer there so why not do that
you know i have all the time in the
world and uh
improving all kinds of skills
but mainly you know i'm interested in
music these days apart from the fitness
you know
[Music]
i work out in gym for two hours and i'm
also passionate about all these things
you know because when we see things in
our experience
um it is very interesting
how do you feel about sangha
or satsang like do you have a spiritual
community around you that you feel like
um you can
be around that you can
easily
yeah like uh
um like
feel a sense of
uh
like
divine or powerful friendship
brotherhood sisterhood with
i do have friends but it is more like
online interaction i'm connected to a
lot of people who ask me questions
sometimes we talk but not very close to
me only these days i mean very recently
people who know me personally they are
getting familiar with my youtube videos
and they're just you know
wondering and
what it is all about they are curious
and uh you know they realize that i'm
doing something but not really
like a satsang or something like that
very close
so it only happens like online i meet
people occasionally video calls chat
and uh
we share our experiences
both you know people who are seeking
who are trying to
get to that point and people who have
already
crossed and that's how that's when i
figured out that many people are
you know struggling with this question
about intentionality
that seems to be a
a weird state of uh to be in you know
because society expects something
different and you think that everything
is perfect i mean you feel it is a
feeling of
nothing needs to be changed life is
beautiful and perfect
right
yeah so there's something like you know
i'm actually working on things like how
to make it more relatable to people
because you know if you say the truth
like for example
i wake up every day looking forward to
how wonderful it is going to be excited
to face a new day but if i say this to
somebody else they wouldn't be able to
relate to it they kind of want to talk
like how difficult and hectic things
have been you know how difficult it is
to get up in the morning to do things so
it is like totally opposite
so yeah i think uh
that is something that i am trying to
find out how to make it more
relatable you have to be honest the same
time you don't you shouldn't irritate or
people you know when you talk about it
when you talk about how amazing life is
that is
really weird because you know
uh it is uh unfortunately people are
we are living in a world where people
think that life is
hectic life is
but life is awesome that is
exactly what it is you know it's amazing
every day it is different unconscious
is another way to say that yeah victim
versus creator consciousness
yes yes yes that's that yeah that's nice
choice of words
there is one friend that i have i talk
to her often
and yeah it's
she's from iran so
it is like you know people are too far
away from me people that i talk to
there is a couple from germany who are
interested in my work they actually came
here
um you know twice to india i met them
and they are still in touch and they
have they are very old they have seen
osho j krishnamurti and many other
people in real life
and
they they allowed my book
the second book is not that i mean uh
selling but uh the first book is uh it
has a lot of good reviews from people it
is about the science and spirituality
the second book is about religions in
general
i wrote a book just to explore the
mystical aspects of all religions to
show how you know
uh
i i thought that book will help reduce
some conflicts so that people understand
that each and every religion has a
mystical aspect which is pretty much the
same like sufism in islam
christian mystic traditions all have
this you know they have similar themes
of uh
getting rid of this you know illusion
and transforming their consciousness
but that book is not uh that i mean uh
it is not very interesting for people i
i guess
i have it here the first this is the
second one
if you haven't seen it you know the
first one is
the truth about spiritual enlightenment
and this is the discovering god book
i love you so much bro
yeah i love you too
so cool
i really feel
like the one
um deeply in you and like when you're
holding up your books like
i just feel so much happiness and so
much um like relatability like deeply
um
if you
yeah if you will at like the soul level
at um at that level of the depth
of what's possible
right yeah
and i love the focus on relatability um
and especially like
bridging into the victim consciousness
because we were there 10 years ago 15
years ago and
yes yes
yeah
yes
and just the small incremental things
but also the bigger like quantum leaps
to make those available at the same time
for
or the cosmic leaps if you will um for
um the other selves to feel less
suffering and to feel more
um
of the divine performance to feel more
of the new separation yeah
wholeness
automatically and then to create from
there
yeah i feel really good about this um
about you and i and what we can further
create together do you also have any
like desire
to because you say um
most of the people that you engage with
most often are further away from you
do you also have desire to
um
like live among
like as we build shambhala the spiritual
kingdom as that gets actualized on the
planet
um
are you interested in uh like joining to
come and live together with powerful
spiritual community that ends up getting
into the thousands and millions of
people um that are all
um about the same vibration
sure yeah that will be that'll be great
to meet people and uh
you know live with them
but i don't um have much idea about it
maybe i have to explore the shambhala i
mean
whatever your your plans but yeah it's
it's uh it sounds like a wonderful
thing to do
beautiful
yeah i'll uh
i'll share
some of
that
um with you
online um a little bit online just um
[Music]
like
yeah if you imagine heaven on earth and
you imagine paradise on earth
and
um
all
basic needs being met
um
the
creator
potential
being so effortlessly activated anytime
you want to generate something it's just
there um
with whatever technologies that are
needed
um energy is so abundant um
the
playfulness the innocence the spiritual
alignment
that that vibration the radiance
of love and light
this like very natural
uh ecological integration with uh
technology and with civilization
um
the
the freedom just total
freedom
um
unity
oneness
just
that um
level of abundance and that level of
choice and freedom and that level of
being amongst
other selves
of that same caliber of that same
frequency and then creating from there
and then of course
merging with our galactic friends at the
same time so
yep so getting rid of that
um yeah
so all of that very interesting yeah and
um so that's being actualized right now
and we'll keep sort of
um
sharing about it um
as much as we feel is is right um along
the journey online but offline i can
also share a little bit more
um
and
[Music]
yeah and the best place to get involved
also the link is always in the bio for
what we're building it's called no limit
society
hundreds of people from around the world
um
waking up becoming free agents for
the ignition of global awakening and
it's perfect so
yeah bentino masaro the team here
um
and the mission is just
there's nothing like it there's nothing
like this mission um
yeah it's the it's the bodhisattva vow
and it's um and it's also
um building heaven on earth paradise on
earth and to not
just
be so non-intentional that um the matrix
forces take over
so
um
so the building of shambhala is the um
obsoleting of the oppressive matrix
contractive
um forces
and so um
yeah so that's
that's all yeah it sounds wonderful yeah
it's
looks like an amazing plan
to help people and you know
to make these things available for
everyone
yeah exactly and
then it radiates out as
like a
radiates out a frequency or a
transmission to the collective for those
that are seeking
union
to come to
shambhalas where their basic needs can
be met where they can
actualize them knowing themselves fully
um they can actualize that potential so
um and just be so abundant like the
abundance is such a big key like it's
such a big key like feeling abundant
like being that's such a big freedom
like so many of the contracted knots
are in the feelings of lack
so yeah
yeah sweet bro i feel really good about
this episode this first one we did
together i feel really good about our
brotherhood
so nice yeah me too
that's a very good
interesting
we went over a lot of things today
yeah and i think this introducing these
books and uh you know the subject is
going to be useful for many people
because i think richard boyle's work
needs a lot of attention it uh it i was
very impressed even i made a video on
his uh
you know work
and i also sent him some emails we
communicated you know
maybe we can
yeah
so i think he will be also happy to
know that his book is i mean reaching
many people
yeah
nice
yeah and maybe even at some point if
he's feeling it we could have a like a
three-person conversation that could be
fun
yes that will be wonderful yeah i have
to just connect with him again it's been
a month a few months
last time i sent him an email
cool
yeah sweet i'll have all of those links
that we discuss in the bio below and
also
thanks everybody we love you so much
thanks for tuning in to this episode
and we would love to hear from you in
the comments below on
how the episode um resonated for you
what some of your key takeaways were um
where you're at in your journey
um maybe
sean mugham and i can actually jump into
the comments and um and respond to you
and engage with you there
um
we would love for you to also like the
video if it brought you value helps the
algorithm subscribe to the channel if
you haven't yet
um
also share the video with
um those that you feel like this would
profoundly impact and resonate with
and similarly this conversation is going
to be up on sean mugan's channel as well
and you can find
um
his channel in the links of
the bio of this video
and then i'll give him the links to um
to
our channel simulation as well and he
can put those in the bio so also
subscribe to his channel go check out
his videos
like his content if it brings you value
share his content that type of stuff you
can find his book links also
on the truth about spiritual
it's enlightenment yeah the truth about
spiritual enlightenment also discovering
god um also his the book of quotes
you'll find all those links in the bio
below um
so yeah check him out and support him
there support the synthesis of
spirituality and science support that
worth that baby yeah thank you
yeah thank you very much
thanks brother
such a pleasure such a pleasure cool
i'll end yeah it was important
it was so good so good my man
um i'm gonna end the recording and then
you and i can stay in the
room for a bit and keep talking okay
sure yeah yeah bye everyone